video showing the moments when police
catch a convicted murderer who had been
at large for days now he escaped from
the southern desert correctional
facility near Indian Springs on Friday
police arrested him at a bus stop near
Owens and Eastern last night now we have
Team coverage today on this story
Vanessa Murphy is at Metro headquarters
she believes she begins our team
coverage where the sheriff wrapped up a
news conference giving us more
information about the escaped inmates
arrest Vanessa
well the concern is the escaped inmate
had a four-day Head Start before police
tried catching him now the focus is how
he could have escaped in the first place
and how no one inside Nevada prisons
noticed he was missing for four days
this is Porfirio Duarte Herrera being
taken into custody last night in
downtown Las Vegas Sheriff Joe Lombardo
pointing out how dangerous the convicted
killer is and acknowledging with a case
of an escaped inmate like him this could
have ended a lot worse as we've reported
sources say the prisoner used a
cardboard dummy in his cell used acid to
corrode metal to escape out of his
window and climbed over a barbed wire
fence the last time he was accounted for
inside the prison was Friday evening the
Department of Corrections saying staff
noticed he was missing Tuesday Morning
the question how could this happen
was the Department of Corrections
invited to this press conference if so
why or why not why aren't they here to
answer our questions I don't know the
answer to that were they invited yes
we reached out to the Department of
Corrections multiple times for answers
and have not received a response
Governor Steve sisilak is calling for an
investigation Sheriff Joe Lombardo
saying he is confident the prison's
Inspector General will do a thorough
investigation now important to note here
Sheriff Joe Lombardo Governor Steve
sisilak are running against each other
in the governor's race Sheriff Lombardo
says as this search was taking place no
one was playing the blame game the focus
was to find that fugitive but again the
question remains how could this happen
reporting live at Metro Police
Headquarters Vanessa Murphy 8 News Now